ヨガ瞑想して何か体験した人が世の中はやっぱり苦しいんだと
何一つも楽しみものはないんだと言うんです
そこの言葉だけ聞いて
無責任な人々は だから仏教もヒンドゥー教も同じじゃないかと
仏教でも世の中は苦しみであると言ってるんですよと
ヒンドゥー教でも私は今話を喋った先生も
やっぱり世の中は徹底的に苦しみだよと言ったんだから
なんであんた方はそんなにもう違う違いませんと言うんですかと
お互いに喧嘩するのは誠に残念なことではないかと
偉そうなことを言うんですね
そういう人と僕 話し合いにならないほどバカバカらしいんですよ
話し合いにもならないんです
そういうこととは随分違うんですよ
この言ってる我々 言ってる世界は
だから でも例えばヨガ瞑想してヨガ瞑想っていうのは
一般的な仏教でない瞑想には
僕は普通のこういう瞑想を使ってます
特別にヨガにヨガ自体批判してるわけじゃないんだけど
普通の瞑想をして 何か禅定を体験した人が
世の中は苦しみであると無意味であるとくだらないというのは
その人の正直な気持ちなんです
それを別に間違ってはないんです
それは その人はよりレベルの高い喜びを知ってるんだからなんです
では 仏教で言っている存在は苦であるということには
梵天も残念ながら入っちゃうんですね
すべての存在も入っちゃうんです
いかなる存在も非存在も
両方も入っちゃうんですね
ですからそこはもう後で説明いたしますからね
じゃあ そういう色界 そこで色界の最後の禅定状態っていうのは
この冷静な心と一体感という 2つなんですね
その時もこの後観察すると
これ以上ないんですかと
優れた 優れた境地が もしかするとさらに瞑想すると優れたことがあるということをなんとなく感じちゃうんですね
そこでどのように感じちゃいますかというと
自分がなぜ一体感を得たんですかと
そこを研究するんですね
そこでわかるのは 自分がこの一体感は
物質のエネルギーと心のエネルギーはきちんともう一つになって行動しているんです
一体になって それは発見するんですね
そういうのは禅定経験ない人々にとっては全くちんぷんかんぷんの話かもしれませんだけど
で 禅定を作るためには
どんな宗教であろうとも何か対象がなければいけません
目で見るものか 耳で聞くことか
体に触れるものか 例えば呼吸瞑想ありますね
インド文化では呼吸瞑想はメインですから
仏教でも呼吸瞑想はもうメインなんですね
みんなインド文化 宗教
文化と言えば 呼吸はもう大事な基盤で考えているんですね
呼吸瞑想も これやっぱり何かに心を繋げておくんですね
物質的な働きに あるいは何か対象を作って
それを見て瞑想するときでも
それに目をちゃんとつけておくんです
それによって一体感が生まれてくる
壁見ていたならば 壁は知識で見てないかもしれませんだけど
それでも壁から入ってくる物質的な情報に心がちゃんとすいちゃって
一つに一緒に流れていくようになる
それは禅定状態なんですね
ですから最後にこの人は発見するのは
自分が物質のエネルギーと自分という心のエネルギーも一緒に行動しているんだと
ですから この不二だと哲学であるでしょ
一切は不二であると 2つはありません
一つですよと 物質も心も同じですよとか
頭では何でも言えますよ
その最初は経験でがございまして
その経験について先人が語る
先人が語ったものを後の人々は哲学する
それは知識の遊びで何の意味もないんです
不二と言ったら後で考えられますでしょう
じゃあ不二と言ったら物質も心も同じだと
もしかすると物質は存在しないかもしれませんと
全ては心かもしれませんと
もう言えるし もしかすると
いえ 全て物質で心はないかもしれませんとか
何でも言えるんですけど
そういうのは全部知識の合理的な頭の考え方であって
仏教ではそういうのはもう単なるヴィタッカだと論理だけですよと
あまり相手にしない お釈迦様相手にしているのは本当に瞑想の体験がある人々の経験だけなんですね
本当の体験があった人の直接的な言葉だけ相手にして
それに何かあるならば批判したり
否化したりはするんです
間違ったら間違いを言ったりする
そういう唯識論とかね
空論とか アドバイタ・ヴェーダーンタですか
このヴェーダーンタの哲学はありますからね
ノンデュアリズムというこの不二という概念はヴェーダのヴェーダーンタ
ヴェーダの最後だと アビダンマと同じなんです
そういうのはもうただの頭の遊びで読めばわかるんですよ
そんな難しい哲学ではないんです
読めばわかる こういうのは読めばわかりますかね
例えば今説明した禅定状態なんかは
私の説明で理解できますかね
できないでしょうに それを体験しなきゃ本当にそんなことあるかないかと
ですから この読めばわかる哲学なんかはね
言葉の遊びで難しくて
すごい難しい優れてる哲学だなというのは
その読んでいる人の知識が発展していないということだけなんです
読めばわかる哲学というのは一つも優れている哲学じゃないんです
で 体験しなきゃわからないことこそがもう優れているんですね
まあそこでこの一体感はどうしてもこの物質と自分の心のエネルギーが一つに行動することから生まれるんだということをわかって
その人がこれは物質を抑えて物質的なエネルギーは
で インドの文化だから物質としてはこの地水火風の立場っていうのはこの昔から発見していたものなんですね
地水火風っていうのは
もうアーユルヴェーダであろうとも
どんな哲学であろうとも出てくる言葉で
解釈はちょっと違いますけど
実体的に解釈しますけどね
でも瞑想すると心はどんどんどんどん成長していっちゃうとこの物質は見えなくなっちゃうんです
見えなくなって直接体験しているのは地水火風であることはわかるんですね
その中でも体験できるのは
まあ4つも体験できませんですけどね
地と風と  かぐらいですね
水はなかなか体験難しいんですけど
でもそれでも難しいんだけども
すぐわかってしまいますよ
ですから 地水火風概念があります
大体瞑想を進んだ人は
この地水火風の次元で
いわゆる現代的に言えば
素粒子レベルで物質の存在は知っていて
素粒子は一番速く行動しているもので
それから心もそれと一緒に行動しているんだと
そこで じゃあこの物質の次元は乗り越えないんではないかと思って
さらに集中するんですね
今まで自分が体験する対象があったんです
例えば光と一緒になったと
壁見て瞑想したならば
壁の色と自分の心の波動が一つに波動波が落ちるようになっちゃう
いわゆる何て言います？その場合はハーモナイズですか
この波動が合わせてしまうんですね
そういう状態だから これなんか
ちょっと飛び出してみようと思っちゃうんですね
そこで その人はすべての物質的な対象が消えた状態を思い浮かんで
それに集中するんです
すべての物質がなくなったならば
言葉で言えば何ですかね
あるのは 空なんですね
いわゆる真空状態 で 自分の心で
例えば目を閉じても 我々は目を閉じて考えてるでしょ
全部映像が浮かぶんじゃないんですか？頭に
で 自分が観念的なものを考えるんだとかね
と思っても そこにいつでも映像があるんです
例えば 人がこう考えるとする
やっぱり嫉妬は良くないなと考えると
自分に何か経験があるんですよ
その経験というのは 自分が嫉妬した経験か
他人の嫉妬の経験か どっちかなんですね
そこで他人の嫉妬だったら
その人を浮かんじゃう
その人が浮かんで その人が嫉妬したところで
あるいは自分に嫉妬したこと
自分が嫌いになった経験か
その人 他の人を嫉妬して
そこでひどい目にあった経験が頭にちゃんと浮かんじゃうんです
映像が それで言葉でやっぱり嫉妬は良くないんだと
自分が抽象抽象的なことを考えたと勘違いするんです
結局 頭の中で映像の流れ
ずっと流れてるんです
ですから 普通の人にはこの抽象的なことは考えられないんですね
数学っていうのは抽象的でしょ？ 正円も実際しないものですけど
でも我々数学をどのように考えますか？ちゃんとエックスプラスワイやらああだこうだとか書いて映像でやってるんです
三角形描いたり 正方形描いたりとか
それで考えられるんです
結局物質なんです で 僕は例えば数学っていうのはね
本当にこの抽象的で抽象的
例えば点という概念がありますね
点という概念は存在しないんですね
一直線ですか それ存在しない
それさえ存在しないのにもよく一直線描くんですよ
黒板に あんなもの一直線じゃなくて
何形ですか 長方形なんですよ
長方形は一直線だと言ってるんですよ
点描いたん それはただの丸ですけどね
丸ですから ちゃんと面積があるんだから
じゃあ描いてみろと ちゃんとしたポイントっていうのは描けませんね
描けませんというか 存在しないんです
でもやっぱりそういう概念
言葉はあるんだけど 結局頭にはちゃんと映像があって
頭には一直線の映像があって
映像で考えてるわけですね
そこでこの これは普通の人間にできないことなんです
とにかく 第5番目の禅定までしっかり進んだ人が
それからこの真空状態
何もない状態を考えて
それに集中しようとする
で いきなりそうできますかというと
それはもう頭の働きによってできないんです
例えば一番瞑想で なんでこの呼吸瞑想は優れていると言ってるんですかというと
素晴らしい瞑想なんですね
すごく入りやすいんです
この真空状態で観察することにも
でも順番でいかなくちゃいけない
最初はやっぱり呼吸は物質であって
形があって 形で感じちゃうんですね
長い呼吸やら短い呼吸やらね
形で感じちゃうんですよ
それ禅定に入って どんどん禅定が進んでいって
やがて形のない瞑想になっちゃうんですね
ですから この無意識界の瞑想をする人が
この全ては全てはじゃなくて空に集中するんです
それは空無辺というんですね
パーリ語でアーカサーなんちゃらやつなんですね
アーカサっていうのは空間という意味で
スペースという意味で
もういわゆる何もない空間なんです
いわゆる真空状態なんですね
アーカサーなんちゃら
で これまた長くして アーヤタナ
アーカサーナンチャーヤタナ
そのアーカサーナンチャーヤタナという言葉は三つに分けちゃうとこういう言葉が出てくるんです
アーカサ アナンタ アーヤタナ
そのアーカサ アナンタ
アーヤタナという三つの言葉をつなげて
アーカサーナンチャーヤタナというこのアビダンマのテキストで出ている言葉作ってるんです
で 今日のこの瞑想の話はまあ理解できないと思いますけど
真剣に聞いた方が役に立つんです
なぜならば これはどんなテキスト読んでも出てこないんです
で テキストに書いているのはすっごい厳密に専門用語を使って書いてるんです
そこはもう理解できない
アーカサ アナンタ アーヤタナという三つの言葉で
このアーカサーナンチャーヤタナという言葉できてるんです
アーカサっていうのは
まあ空なんです で その場合の空というのは空間であって
例えば何かあると まず例えばお月様を見ている
そこ それからそこにお月様がないという状態
そこに空間なんですね
そこでその人がもう何か物質的な流れがエネルギーと自分と一体になってるんですね
そこで一体感だからものすごい大きく感じてるんですね
そこは自分が今感じてる物質的な存在がない状態を結構難しいんです
お月様を見て そのお月様があるところにそれがない状態を観察するんだから
この部屋にいるならば
部屋には何もない状態を観察するんだから
そういうのは あの馬鹿げた頭だけの話じゃない
そういう状態は確実になるんです
この部屋は何もない 空っぽにすることはできますからね
だからここはもう集中力が抜群にある人だから
第5番目まで禅定進んでるんだから
だからもうそれから訓練しているんだから
5つすりの訓練はね だから希望次第に物事を観察することができます
それで自分がこの自分
今まで経験した体験あるでしょ？盆栽一任か何とかとかね
その体験はない状態 何もない状態を観察する
真空状態 それをアーカサというんですね
アナンタっていうのは
無辺というキリがない
無辺という意味なんですね
そこでこの辺という日本語の言葉で言っているのは
この境界ですか 境界を作るのは物質なんですね
宇宙 物質あるんだから
宇宙には大きさがあるんです
で 建物を作ったらそこにもう空間がもう決めちゃうんですね
建物を壊しちゃったら
もう空間はもう大きくなっちゃうでしょうに
ですから この物質を観察しているんだから
今までその人にとっては自分の心はあるレベルに囲まれていると
自分という自我の存在がね
とわかってるんですね
そこで物質を消えちゃったら
もうキリがないんですね
真空状態はどれくらい大きいかと言っちゃったら
そこは話にならないでしょうに
真空状態は無辺であって
何か物質がある状態は有辺であるんですね
ですからアナンタン 無辺ですと
だから瞑想対象はアーカサン・アナンタンという瞑想をやってるんです
言葉は使うならば 瞑想にも何か言葉を使うでしょ
ですから アーカサンということは認識して
そこで無辺であること
今自分が有辺なんですね
第5番目の戦場にいる場合は
何か対象あるんだから
そこで対象が消えたならば無辺だろうということで
アーカサンという状態を観察する
アーカサンっていうのは真空状態
空間だけ観察する それ観察しちゃうと
それにまた自分が一つになっちゃうんです
いわゆる今までやった瞑想対象
これは消えちゃうんです
何もなくなっちゃう で
私のこれは誤解かもしれませんだけど
そこまでは行った形跡はないんですね
この他の仏教 宗教では
色界進んでるなとか いろいろ現代でもこのいろいろ瞑想体験ある人々のテキストとかね
ラーマクリシュナですか
そういういろいろな人がいるっていう話があるんだけど
やっぱりみんな色界 何か戦場
第1戦場ぐらいとかあるような感じがするんだけど
やっぱりもう魂があると
神がいる 梵天があるとかいう状態にいるんですね
そこでその今まで味わってたこの尊い体験を何のことなく消えちゃう
消えて 何もない真空状態ということを認識しちゃうんですね
そうするとさらに心の波がものすごく細かくなるんです
荒波がさらにさらに細くなる
もう概念なんかもうまるっきりない
考えることは全くない
ただいるだけ いるだけいて
何も見えない 何も聞こえない
体の感覚は全く感じない
自分がここにいるいるという概念さえないんです
その人とは体が綺麗に消えてるんです
呼吸もしないんです このこの戦場では
すごい優れてるテーラワーダなんです
で 次の言葉はアーヤタナという
アーヤタナっていうのは一応状態という意味なんですね
レベル 状態 ステート で
その人は真空状態 真空の無辺
無辺たる真空の状態を観察して
その状態を体験する それは無色界の第1番目の戦場なんです
アーカサ・アナンタ・アーティ
その状態に入ったところで
やっと物質と心の働きが分かれるんです
そこまでは心が物質に依存して波を打ってるんです
心が物質から刺激を受けて波を打ってるんです
人間ではすごく分かりやすい
気持ちよくなりたい人々は麻薬を使っているでしょうに
麻薬という物質は脳細胞に入っちゃって
脳細胞いろいろ混乱を起こしちゃって
もう気持ちいい感じを作ってくれる
気持ちいいと感じるのは心なんですけど
やっぱりそれは物質の刺激で気持ちよくなるんですから
我々の心というのはいつでも物質の刺激で回転しているんです
色界の瞑想をしても 物質から出てくる刺激で心が回転しているんです
そこでやっと物質はない状態
完成したところで 心が物質から離れて自分だけで回転することができるようになっちゃうんです
その時はもう概念は全くない
概念というのは何かに触れたら刺激生まれたら生まれるんだから
何にもない心はある一定の決まってるパターンで
ある一定のすごい規則正しい波で活動し始めるのです
今我々の心は全然規則正しい波じゃないんです
見ると生まれる波と聞くと生まれる波が随分違うんです
波の周波数と波動とかなんとかとか
ですからすごい 混乱状態
波で書くならば 普通の人が普通に
我々の心はもういろいろこうこうやって
こうこうやって いろいろ波なんですね
こうやったり こうこうやったりとか
人間の心臓の働く波みたいに
で この色界のなったらかなり荒っぽい波ですけど
いくらかこんな感じの波になるんですね
無色界になっちゃうと
ものすごいきめ細かいんだけど
すごい丁寧に幅木持ってあって
もうこんな風なもう丁寧な波なんですね
幅も大きさも全部決まってあって
その丁寧に波が押すんですね
こういう恐ろしい波ではないのです
そういうふうに波で説明すると
そのような差なんですね
例えば光も波ですけど
だいたい光は一直線で書くでしょ
なぜかというと すっごく細かい波なんですね
ですから ほぼ一直線みたいな状態でもう薄い波
心が波打っているんです
そこまであまりもうそれはもう常識では理解できません世界だから
理解できませんだから
そこら辺 一応言葉だけでも理解してください
私の説明は難しいと思っても
それより簡単にはどこにも説明してないんです
わかるかないか このテキストもいくらか注釈あると思いますけど
読んでみてください わかるかないか
で 色界 違う言葉で説明するならば
色界の戦場っていうのは
自分が何かを体験するレベル
無色界の戦場っていうのは
何かを体験するじゃなくて
この自分という心が何かになるレベル
何かを体験しても何かになりますけどね
面白いものを見ると面白くなる
面白くないものを見ると面白くなくなっちゃうという
何かによって心は変化する
無色界では何によってではなくて
心は自分で変化していく
自分だけで いわゆる色界は何かを体験する次元で
無色界は何かを体験するじゃなくて
何かになる次元なんですね
心が ですから 心は何かを体験する次元と
心が何かになる次元という風に
まあ単なる言葉の遊びですけどね
まあそういう風にも言葉では説明できるんです
無色界の 1番目の禅定はアーカーサーナンチャーヤタナと言うんです
じゃあ 2番目に行きます
1番目わからなかったら
もうさっぱり 2番目はわからないと思います
あの五取禅定っていうのは
お釈迦様悟る前にもう世の中にあったもんなんです
あったことは今 今現代あるヒンドゥー教の哲学本を見るでも
そのあったことの後ですか
もうあるんです いる言葉として残ったりとか
で 次は何でしたっけ？ヴィンヤーナンチャーヤタナ
2番目はヴィンヤーナンチャーヤタナで読むんですね
ヴィンヤーナンチャーヤタナ
それはカットして見るとこういう風な言葉が出てくるんですね
ヴィンヤーナ それからアナンタ
それからアーヤタナ ヴィンヤーナっていうのはもう大体もう聞き慣れてる言葉
色 心 アナンタっていうのは無限
制限ないという 無制限的で無限という
アーヤタナっていうのは状態
まあ言葉はそれだけのことで
問題はその瞑想はどうしますかということで
そこは無色界の 1番目の禅定ない人にはもう絶対不可能であって無理なんです
この心の成長の状態は順番で行かなくちゃ
もう順番なんです それを飛んだりすることはもう不可能なんです
法則ですからね 法則だから
例えば車はいくらスピード出しちゃっても空には飛べないでしょうに
スピード出せば出すほど地面に触れる
あれはもうエネルギーですか？引力です
それは少なくなるかもしれません
どこかで飛び出してしまうかもしれません
それですじ閉まっちゃうだけですけど
空は飛べない 空を飛べるためにはスピードもあって
やっぱり空気抵抗をいただいて
そこで止まってもらわなきゃいけない
空には飛べない ですから
飛行機は空を飛べますけど
車はできないんですね
そういうことで やっぱりもう車で空飛べたと思ったって無理ですから
そういうふうに普通の瞑想しないで
じゃあヴィンヤーナンチャーヤタナイきなりやってみようかなと思っても
それ無理なんです ヴィンヤーナンチャーヤタナできるのはアーカーサーナンチャーヤタナ体験した人にだけ
そこで同じくお釈迦様の指導はアーカーサーナンチャーヤタナ
空 無限 無限という禅定に入った人が何を体験するかというと
単なる真空状態だけなんです
真空状態だから無限なんだ
当たり前で それを体験するんです
物質は体験しない 真空状態に地水火風は働いてないんだから
で そこを禅定を成功したならば
これ難しいんだから 心と物質はもう離す
離すんだから 引き離すんだから
これすごい難しいんです
ですから 何回何回も同じ経験を入る
繰り返して繰り返して繰り返す
これが第1番目の訓練
それから長い時間いる訓練をする
それから自分で時間決めて決めてる時間いるようにする
何回何回も入る それから長い時間いられるように訓練する
その 2番目でもやっぱり自然に禅定が止まりますからね
次の訓練は自然に止まるんじゃなくて
自分で決まってる時間で止まれるようにする
それ終わったらまあ早く入ること
訓練する すぐ禅定に入るようにできるだけどれぐらい速さで禅定の状態になるか
訓練は同じですけどね
それも終わったらもう最後のパッキャエクカナ
パッキャエクカナもとことんする
パッキャエクカナも禅定に入るたびにしなくちゃいけないんです
禅定に入ったら それ終わったらすぐちょっと観察しなさい
後の観察ですか そういう風にして訓練できたところで
またこれで終わりかと自分に聞くでしょう
今 真空状態と自分が一体になってるんだから
じゃあそれで終わりますかと
言うと その人はわかるのはこの真空状態があったんだから
自分がこの禅定を体験したことなんです
いわゆる物質があって
物質がもう嫌だともう終わったんだけど
物質に支えられて物質のない状態を考えて
それを体験しているんだから
やっぱり真空状態に いわゆるアーカサという空無辺状態に頼っていたんだということは自分でわかるんですね
じゃあそれに頼らないで心は自由にならないかと
真空状態を創出したところで
心の限らない働きがわかったんだから
やっぱり何か杖を持って手すりを持って登ったことになってますからね
じゃあ手すりなしに登ってみようではないかということになっちゃうんです
一直線を鉛筆で引こうと思ったら
あの 何て言いますか あの
え？え？定規？定規 定規を使いますからね
でもそれも精密に引けますよ
でも何も使わないで フリーハンドで一直線引けばもうすごい上手なんですね
ですから じゃあフリーハンドで引けるかというふうな感じで
今は心はこの無辺状態になったのは真空という定規を使って
ですから そこもなしに無辺の状態を体験してみようと思うんですね
それでも条件なしにできない
そこで違う条件を使うんです
その違う条件というのは真空状態体験
ところで 自分の心があったんですね
その心は無辺の状態にいたんですね
その前の心の状態 無辺の心の状態
それを支えにとっちゃうんです
それを定規に使うんです
いわゆる第1禅定が第2禅定の瞑想対象になる
あるいは第1禅定が まあ一直線描くような例えで言えば
第1禅定を定規に使って第2禅定に入るんです
ちょっと難しいんですけどね
まあそんなに考えるのは難しくないんですよ
第1禅定  第1禅定じゃないです
これはまあ6番目  7番目ですけどね
無色界の 1番目 禅定の世界では6番目
禅定の世界で6番目に入るためには
この空無辺ということを考えたんです
空無辺を体験したんだから
空無辺体験したっていうのは
心が体験したんだから
それで心無辺というふうに真空状態っていうのはあるものじゃないんだから
結局は そこに心が広がっちゃったんだから
色無辺ということを観察するんです
色は無辺に流れていくんだと
そうすると真空状態の支えがなくて
また無辺の状態 また体験する
禅定としてはほとんど同じなんです
もうちょっとレベル高い
心のレベル高いだけなんです
その時はまあ舎の状態で喜びも何も気絶感も何も感じない
ただあの平静な状態なんです
そこで色ヴィンヤーナは色
アナンタは無辺 アーヤタナというのは状態
心は無辺であったこと
第1禅定では心は無辺であったことを体験
その体験に基づいてまた認識を働かす
集中力を働かす 瞑想する
そうすると また一体感が生まれてくる
その一体感はものすごいレベル高くて
もう物質の支えはほとんどない
まあどうしてもないんだけど 1
番目には なんて言いますかね
逆説的に物質は支えてくれたんですね
物質がない状態と考えたんだから
物質は裏であってない状態だから
今は心が無辺であるということを観察するんです
それに支えて この心無辺という禅定に入るんです
で  3番目に行きます  3番目はアーキンチャンヤータナと呼ぶんです
で こちらこの文法的にこうなりますけど
言葉分析すると この言葉なんです
アキンチャナ アーヤタナ
このあの その禅定の名前などなどは全部お釈迦様が決まってる名前で
ですからものすごい厳密に徹底した厳密でこういう言葉を選んでいるんです
それはすっごい究極的に心理学的なんです
宗教的ではないんです
全く そういう言葉を持ってお釈迦様は世界にあるすべての瞑想体験を説明しようとしているんです
科学的に ですから この言葉は理解してもわかると思います
アキンチャナという言葉を見てみましょう
アーキンチャナヤータナという第3番目の禅定状態
それはアキンチャナという状態ですよと
アキンチャナっていうのはパーリ語でキンチクという言葉がございます
キンチクのサムシング
何かという意味で アキンチャナっていうのはその否定形でナッシングという意味なんです
ナッシング 何もない これ真空とは違うんです
空とは違うんです これ一番目は空無辺と言うでしょ
それをもう飛んでいって
何もない これ虚無という意味ではないんです
言葉ではもうナッシングという意味なんです
ナッシングネス 人間にはそれはナッシングということは想像できない
我々はナッシングと言ったら
何かあるものに基づいてないということを理解しますから
で どういうことでしょうかね
これはこういう説明なんです
第2番目の禅定は色無辺定
というんですね 心は無辺である